Columbo the capital of Sri Lanka
a country that was known more for its 26
years civil war than its pristine sandy
beaches
Columbo is very much a crossroads today
freedom has brought a burst of energy in
creativity the most magnificent mix of
color and sound and vitality that you
don't find anywhere else since its civil
war ended in 2009 Colombo has become the
fastest growing city destination in the
world and a visit right now will reveal
a place forging a new identity before
your very eyes I think now is the time
if anyone really wants to come they
should be coming to Colombo and while
the tourist guides may give a flavour of
the city
nothing beats local knowledge if you're
here in Colombo Nicky don't miss it the
great times to walk and have this downer
food three Colombians are taking you off
the beaten track see what they see and
learn what they love about their
remarkable city
my name is Sonali Dharma Varginha I was
born and bred in Colombo I'm a fashion
designer I'm also an artist and I
specialize in heritage art of batik
batik is a form of wax resist that
people over the years have used to value
add to fabric from this humble workshop
Sonali runs a top fashion label in Sri
Lanka using centuries-old techniques you
definitely won't find places like this
in the travel brochures but Colombo is a
city that invites those who want to look
behind the scenes when you're in Colombo
it'll be rare that people will not allow
you to come and take a look at things
they're doing with 80s cooking something
in a restaurant or if you come to my
workshop in someone says I like to see
how botique is done you can actually
experience forced and
there's an old-world charm about it and
still there's a little bit of village
life right in the heart of the city here
in Colombo creative businesses like
sonali's are now uniquely accessible to
any curious traveler it's an opportunity
that reflects a newfound freedom I was
very much a kid who grew up during that
time of war it was pretty much like
being a caged animal there was so little
freedom with what we could do
however today freedom has brought a
burst of energy in creativity in in any
anything you don't feel stifled if you
want to taste a bit of Colombo's
creative surge then there's no shortage
of restaurants gaining international
attention little by little we are we are
showing showcase into the world what our
cuisines
during the war the old Dutch hospital in
the heart of Colombo was used by the
military now it's home to a restaurant
that's been voted one of the best in
Asia Colombo waking up we are seeing so
many influences of other countries
coming in uh yeah I think we get to show
cares more what we have darshan Mooney
tosser his owner of the Ministry of
crowd he's also a celebrity chef
spearheading Colombo's culinary
revolution of which his restaurants are
just a taste the crab it's a product of
Falcon and the Singaporeans have been
taking it away from us for the last 40
years I wanted to bring it back and
that's why the restaurant name was
Ministry of that he believes visitors to
Colombo have to experience restaurants
like this we're rich colonial history
meets modern world-class cuisine
the colonial history actually resulted
in all this so this is a building built
by the Dutch almost 350 years ago and
Columbia is so many beautiful English
architectural buildings built by the
British and they're all getting used up
as entertainment industry before
restaurants for shopping and I think we
are creating something that's unique to
South Asia you don't see this happening
in say Singapore and Dubai because they
don't they would not have buildings this
old and I think it's a celebration of
our colonial past
Columbo was recently ranked the fastest
growing city destination in the world
yet some of the city's best experiences
are in places run by locals for locals
when you come to Sri Lanka there is one
thing you must do you must go to Peter
market to take in the sights and sounds
and smells of Columbus Gabi White is an
Australian expert who's been living and
working in Colombo for 21 years she
believes there's only one way to tour
this sprawling shopping district in the
back of a tuk-tuk if you're the
wealthiest Sri Lankan or the poor Sri
Lankan everyone end up in pedo market
this market will give you a window into
the life of Colombians like no other
but for Gabi it's the spices that give
Petter its unique flavor you find when
you go to different people's houses they
always have a different spice mix and
you know it some people prefer more
cardamom some people prefer more chili
powder some people prefer more clothes
in there their food so this is where
shops like this that exist is really
fantastic
because people have had their spice
traditions passed down from their
grandmothers their great-grandmother's
you know here you get to actually look
and feel and touch and smell you know
and the smell is amazing you can find
just about anything in petter market be
prepared to negotiate a price and always
do it with a smile Sri Lankans do
everything with a smile and I think it
helps if you also do everything with a
smile and you'll always be looked up
it's lunchtime at the Ministry of crowd
what's this steamed crabs in crab pond
Aria the DAR shuns having a catch up
with his partner in the restaurants
Kumar Sangakkara it's been a good
experience opening this place I've been
seeing that you know Sri Lankans really
embrace it it's a risk as well you don't
know whether people we like this but the
last three years have proved that people
are really ready
Kumar knows as well as anyone that food
isn't the only thing that unites people
in this country
he's one of Sri Lanka's all-time
greatest cricketers whether you know the
rules of cricket or not if you want to
understand Colombo you need to
experience this national obsession and
you don't need to get tickets to the big
stadiums here to enjoy the sport
strength cricket is the absolute
quintessential essence of Colombo you
know it doesn't matter where you travel
throughout Colombo there is always a
match going on in some little nook or
cranny some little backyard some back
street Gabby and her husband run the
Cricket Club cafe a well-known
restaurant and bar in Colombo and she'll
often find impromptu games happening
right outside the front door and
anyone's welcome to take part if you
turn up to watch a match or just you
know observe it from the side of the
road you quite often get shrunk and
calling you over to compare to come and
join in they would love nothing than to
be showing off their skills and get
foreigners involved to show them how
good they are at cricket they can never
stop talking about it really
recreational time is less about sport
for Sonali and more about picnics with
friends on Colombo sandy beaches
tourists might hit the sound during the
day but locals go when the beaches are
really at their best after work in
evening by the beach watching the sunset
you need to see this the the nuances of
color as the Sun sets and on the waters
change from it's incredibly blue of the
day to a new color palette by evening
and it's so amazing mount lavinia beach
is her favorite three miles of golden
sands just a stone's throw from the city
center because we're an island nations
are surrounded by portals the beaches
are amazing mount lavinia is a well
known hangout but for Sonali it's best
to be enjoyed with a takeaway hamper
this is actually very authentic Sri
Lankan food and you can bite on the
streets on on banana leaves that's how
they the package so it's available
everywhere and easy fresh food so it's
good to eat
being on the west coast of the island
Colombo isn't short of special spots to
watch the sunset
but for sonali it doesn't get any better
than here on the beach a few miles up
the coast in the historic heart of the
city his golf face green I come here
sometimes as my restaurant oh man a
minute is my parameter dad way to walk
between them for the sunset and
inspiration darshan may not have far to
walk but people come here from all over
the city after sunset he's not alone in
thinking it's the very best place to
experience Colombo at night you'll get
food vendors kites being flown and I
think it's something charming about
all-time pastimes that something simple
as a kite is still flowing out there and
the food are influenced by the different
ethnic groups of this country if you're
here in Colombo make sure you don't miss
it it's a great time to walk and have
this kind of food everyone walks through
this place to see the old hotel
bald-faced hotel afternoon tea at the
hotel come over here
Santa this Grand promenade was
established by the British in the 19th
century today it's the unique atmosphere
the DAR shuns particularly keen to share
this ambiance - I mean you don't get
anywhere right the Indian Ocean is like
10 feet away from you
their saltiness in there the winds in
your hair it's an amazing place to come
while Colombians are proud of the
history and culture there's an emerging
night scene in Colombo you might not
expect I feel a little sad that people
look at us as a third-world country
and when you say you're from Sri Lanka
sometimes people don't know where you're
from and they have a perception that we
are still an uncivilized nation
Columbo is very much a crossroads
between a Western culture and the
traditional part of it
Sonali is showcasing her latest desires
at Colombo Fashion Week but tonight is
as much about fun as fashion Colombo is
much of a social life days anything will
get in any other part of the world and I
think it's important for people to come
and experience that so you will have a
little bit of that old-fashioned
old-world charm and then there will be
this buzzing very international
multicultural flavor that gives it a
happy balance we're just given birth to
peace as it were it's a fresh time I
think now is the time if anyone really
wants to come they should be coming to
Colombo
tonight's show has been a huge success
but for Columbo the party's just getting
started